q is with us to start off this hour in
st. Louis thank you how are you I'm
doing good how are you doing better than
I deserve what's up so I called a couple
months ago and you gave me FPU from my
mom because I was taking it and we went
through the class I'm trying to be her
biggest supporter and we kind of have
some bills that are entangled so I feel
like it's my duty to try to help her but
the problem is she won't stick to the
budget like I do the budget and then
well me and her she does her budget and
then I go over there and I could take in
things like that but then she goes and
does whatever she wants so I'm not
really sure if I should just separate
all of our bills and kind of let her do
her own thing
yeah or if I should keep trying to help
her plan no you should separate your
bills which you probably should have
done anyway I separated my car insurance
last year but we still have children so
25 okay and you live with her
no I live on my own but she's on my
cellphone plan and I did stupid and I
co-signed the car for her okay
well we need to get the car refinanced I
need to get it sold okay because she's
not going to handle money she told you
that loud and clear she went through the
world's best nine week class and is
ignoring everything we told her to do I
can't help her okay you can't help her
until she's ready to be helped you and I
are both trying to make this woman do
something she doesn't want to do it's
like she wants to do it's like she does
know she won't do it she talks about it
yeah but she didn't do it people that
want to do something do it if you want
to do something you can do it maybe
stick into a budgets not rocket science
it does not require some Herculean task
of self-control
it just says I'm gonna look down and I'm
gonna make my money behave and I'm gonna
behave in line up with this and I'm
gonna stick to it and she writes it all
down then goes and does whatever flip
she wants to do translation she went to
the class to please you she had no
intention of changing ever am I wrong
I love ya I'm afraid she's gonna find
pain before she finds the will to change
okay and I don't want you tied up in the
pain I want you to suggest that we get
that car refinanced or sold as soon as
possible and your and tell her you're
really scared about this because she
won't stick to a plan and that's making
you make these tough decisions because
of her continued misbehavior that's
after I gave her the class and you guys
went to the class together yeah she was
there every week I missed one week
because I went to smart money but other
than that we did everything in the class
and she just won't do it no I can't you
can lead a horse to water you know the
saying right and you can lead mom
through the class but I can't make her
drink it seemed to Xavier to drink would
you can't make her drink